هناك يعني استمرار وتفاوت في الاعداد من
القادمين الى السودان ربما بحسب بعض
الاحصائيات بان هذا المال كذا او هذا
المعبر يشهد اكبر نسبه اقبال من القادمين
من السودان الايام الاخيره والساعات
الاخيره الكثير من الذين ياتون من
السودانيين انفسهم يعني هناك بالفعل نسب
من المصريين وليس من الاجانب كنت قد تتحدث
منهم البعض يعني الارقام او الاحصائيات
الدقيقه تظهر مع نهايه هذا اليوم المشهد
معتاد هناك الحافلات التي تنتظرهم وتتجه
بهم الى اسوان او الى القاهره ربما كان
المشهد الابرز او الحديث الابرز مع من كنت
اتحدث معهم او اغلب
او اغلب من كنت اتحدث معهم هي فكره المقوس
لفتره طويله جدا داخل المعبر سواء من
الجانب السوداني او داخل المعبر المصري
حتى الخروج وبالتالي ربما كانت هذه هي
النقطه التي كانت محل تعليق ولكن هذه
النقطه من جانبها السلطات المصريه اوضحت
بان هذا المعبر ربما يعني لم يكن هذا
المعبر الذي تم انشاؤه عام 2016 لم يكن
مخصص لان يكون مكانا لتدفق عدد كبير من
المواطنين هو في البدايه وفي النهايه كان
من المخصص ان يكون معبد لي الشاحنات
والبضائع ومن ثم كان هذا الاندفاع الكبير
من النازحين الذين يقدرون بالالاف كان
سببا بالاضافه ايضا الى اهميه ان يكون
هناك تدقيق امني اللقط الذي خلق اثير من
البعض حول عدم حصول تاشيره
التاشيره مسبقه التاشيرات المسبقه كانت
مطلوبه بين 18 والخمسين من هم اصغر ومن هم
اكبر هم فقط
المستثنون من هذه العبور عمليات التدقيق
التفتيش الكشف عن الصحف الجنائيه لضمان
عدم دخول عناصر ارهابيه متسلله كل هذه
العناصر والعوامل ربما هي التي كانت سببا
في هذا التاخير الكبيره الذي كان محل شكوى
على الجانب الاخر ايضا هناك من كان ينتظر
من السودانيين الذين يرغبون في العوده الى
السودان على الجانب الاخر والذين ايضا
انتظروا لفتره الساعات امتدت الى ايام حيث
ان لوجستيات الانتقال داخل هذا المعبر لها
علاقه بالحافلات وعمليه الحافلات التي
تنتقل من الجانب السوداني الى الجانب
المصري لتقوم بنقل السودانيين المنتظرين
هنا للعوده بهم مره اخرى الى داخل حدود
السودان وهو ما يعني تحرك بعض الشيء خلال
الساعات الاخيره حتى الان هناك يعني
اهتمام كبير جدا من السلطات المصريه في
تقديم ربما العون بقدر المستطاع الى
السودانيين القادمين سواء اذا تحدثنا عن
سيارات اسعاف او هلال احمر داخل المعبر
لتقديما مساعدات الطبيه خصوصا مع ساعات
الارهاق مع رحلات القدوم وايضا الموكوس
داخل هذا المعبر ايضا كان هناك قرار
القطارات توفير عدد اكثر من القطارات
لمساعده السودانيين الذين يتجهون من اسوان
اقرب مدينه من هنا الى العاصمه القاهره كل
هذه الامور كانت محله اهتمام خلال الساعات
الماضيه بمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات